I hate Twitter I think about deleting
mine all the time what I don't like is
that constant posturing that goes on
there people just can't seem to help
themselves from pointing out what is
good and what is bad or how others are
bad and you are good to a point where it
almost becomes fiction just to satisfy
this need and I don't mind that this
happens I understand that it does but
what annoys me most about it is that it
gets rewarded through social media we
get likes we get engagement by boasting
about certain things it's very popular
a classic example could be JK Rowling
changing the sexual identity
retroactively Leon our characters as a
way to posture for social virtue points
this to me is a good example because
most understand that it's complete
[ __ ] but it's not always easy to
tell what is genuine online contrasting
this using sports as an example
previously we have for thousands of
years rewarded the winners the people
who act the ones who run the fastest
swim the fastest score the most goals
etc etc we don't reward the ones who say
they run the fastest but thanks to
social media this is someone become
backwards you get rewarded for saying
things that make you seem virtuous
rather than acting on it obviously this
is not nearly to the same extent but it
explains why the site has become such a
cesspool of opinion and how more often
than not the people who boast about
being virtuous often reveals to be
hiding the fact that through action they
are not I feel like there's so many
youtubers that could call out but what
is virtue then and what makes someone
actually virtuous well luckily this is
answered by ancient Greek philosopher
Aristotle according to Aristotle the
path that leads to virtue is also the
path that leads to happiness or a happy
life I find it kind of humorous with the
neverending self-help books that exists
that still tries to answer this question
today when it was answered over 2,000
years ago by the ancient Greek word
eudaimonia what does this mean keep
watching we'll explore please watch
first I just want to say I think it's so
[ __ ] cool the more I study ancient
Greek philosophy the more I'm just
amazed by it first we had Socrates one
of the arguably greatest philosophers of
all time who taught using that word
loosely
by the way Plato my favorite philosopher
an amazing writer and Plato then created
his famous school the Academy which iris
tatl then enrolled in and Aristotle has
been described as the great the one
philosopher I mean what a lineage but
wait it goes on Aristotle also taught
Alexander the [ __ ] great I didn't
know this how insane is this the guy
that took over the [ __ ] world anyhow
in the book Nicomachean ethics by
Aristotle it wasn't actually written by
Aristotle it's notes taken down from his
lectures by his son Nicky mcian some
argue this is the most important work of
philosophy ever written and in it we get
the answer what is virtue according to
Aristotle virtue is habit what this
means is that it can't be taught
you can't teach someone how to be a good
person or how to act the right way
instead it's something that comes
through practice one good act doesn't
make you a virtuous person instead it's
something that you have to keep
practicing through action and through
habit can achieve after reading this I
find myself looking at my own upbringing
and how habit has shaped Who I am
I never realized us how much of my whole
life and my whole being is based on
habit my moral my choices all of this if
you strip down this idea of right action
through habit you could compare it to
machine learning or self taught AI which
actually works similar to how a human
brain functions and learns just in a
massively simplified way for example if
a self-taught AI wants to learn how to
walk they need a motivating factor for
that to happen it could be moving from
point A to B in the shortest amount of
time and that's the function that they
need to maximize when it learns it tries
different behaviors many times over and
over until it finds the most satisfying
path which achieves that function
basically developing habits of behavior
to achieve their goal so then looking at
as humans
what is our motivating function what is
it that drives us every day to get out
of bed and the answer according to
Aristotle is happiness happiness is the
root function for all our actions if you
make an example out of this you could
say what if you want $100,000 what would
you do with that amount if you say you
want to buy something materialistic like
a car you can then ask again well why do
you want a car you may answer Oh to get
from point A to point B
well why do you want to go from point A
to point B you may answer to achieve a
certain goal and why do you want to
achieve a certain goal well
achieving goals makes you happy
similarly if you said well I want to
save my money because I hope in the
future that it will make you happy so
then if happiness is our function then
why aren't we all happy why is it so
difficult well it's complicated and
difficult to achieve
since virtue is achieved through action
and habit helps us guide us through
those actions
iris Tata points out that there's an
excess and efficiency to each of our
actions he describes this with a couple
different examples which I think is kind
of funny because his goal is to describe
what makes someone virtuous but when I
read it it just made me think of how
many ways you can fail as a human if
you're too scared of something then
you're a coward but if you're too
fearless then you're overconfident
iris taught will put a lot of emphasis
on communication if you get offended by
humor too much then that makes you
boring if you make too many jokes then
you are seen as unserious if you're too
sad you're depressed if you are not sad
enough you might seem cold or unbothered
about certain things he lists out many
of these examples on how to fail as a
human but he points out that between
each of these examples there lies the
golden mean no not the golden mean the
golden mean it's here that the virtuous
person acts each time and through habit
only can you find this mean in each
situation you find yourself in but he
also puts emphasis on the capacity of
each person some of us can only act
within a certain frame based on who we
are for example say you see a fire in a
building happen and you run in to save
someone which is seen as brave and
virtuous but if you're not strong enough
to act on this you could get trapped in
the house along with the person and then
causing more harm you should therefore
understand your capacity to act and then
in instead call the fire department as a
way to help and through that way you act
virtuous within your own capacity this
leads us back to the word eudaimonia
which technically translates to
happiness and it's a state of well-being
that you achieve by finding the golden
mean through right action and through
habit but what the word really means
isn't happiness it's more human
flourishing for many of us there exists
a gap between what we perceive
selves being capable of and what we have
actually achieved and this gap creates
anxiety for us for some there might even
be the opposite situation where you are
able to achieve more but you just don't
recognize it yourself eudaimonia isn't
there for being happy all the time that
would just be another extreme to the
mean but rather is acting virtuous
because you enjoy being virtuous and
it's realizing your potential and acting
upon it that is the key to happiness
that is the key to eudaimonia and that
is my summary of Nicomachean ethics by
the way [ __ ] Twitter